this is the last king of their sting it
we got for today christina position
huh terminator 5. from new jersey
oh what's up mariah got a quick king at
her sing it for you guys what do you
think about girls with gaps in their
teeth
oh damn michael straight what do you
think because you girls got one
love you guys gang gang buzz buzz gang
gang
i think that [ __ ] it's dope god made you
like that for a reason man the worst one
people cover them up
they get veneers or something to rock
the gap i used to have gap man
i knew it mine's going i knew it three
gaps though
that's just bad teeth she just has that
oh you just have bad teeth
i couldn't eat man i couldn't keep food
in my mouth i put super mouth coming
right back you got a purty mouth
whoa oh [ __ ] what am i talking you got a
gap dog yeah
well let's bring up they have a
beautiful model that has a gap too her
name is lauren will you look her up
beautiful model madonna has a gap
does she yeah uh michael strahan who
else and we're talking about women
becky g used to have a gap and then she
got that fixed
damn why do people get it that's 7 10
split baby that's what i'm saying
straight hand got that 7 10 split man
that's a big gap
yeah here's the yeah but also if you
think about how wide maybe his
his whole bone structure is it just
didn't make sense
that many teeth aren't going to be able
to get the job he got tired
his teeth are all holding each other's
hands like this yeah they got tired man
yeah man because he got can we look up
beautiful
model teeth gap older older
older yeah this lady's a senior i think
her yeah on the right yeah right there
what's her name
who's that lauren
aykroyd or something yeah you got him
for a reason man i think you rocked that
[ __ ]
yeah there was a ring girl for bellator
that's hosting jay bryce she's so hot
she's super smoking
that's her laura hutton laura hutt and
lauren hutton
uh yeah hey bring up jade bryce
this is something theo can slam his dick
to a book later bring this up
if you have a painting over i might be
interested yeah it's got to be a
painting
jade bryce uh
yeah she is so freaking hot yep she got
a gap
yes yes sir
yep just click on her teeth i think
cat's better looking
cat doesn't have a gap oh thanks theo
cat doesn't have it i still think that's
prettier though
there you go and also that woman just
got out of the shower where is she
she's working out oh my bad debate club
jade bryce or lauren hutton
what do you say debate club uh jade or
lauren no they're both beautiful ladies
that they almost these ladies almost
look similar a little bit if you look
like mother-daughter type of situation
yeah now is there um i think
freckles are cool too anyway that's
freckles you don't have any freckles
well you're getting crazy man you like
freckles
what are you just in a giving mood today
yeah no one has freckles you already
said he looked real tan
yeah would you watch a miracle on 34th
street yesterday or something he did
come in 10.